joining me right now is a man who was an
mvp of the super bowl back in the day
and also a heisman trophy winner
and one of my favorites uh part of
college game day which will emanate this
saturday from augusta national
he is desmond howard how are you des i'm
doing well i can't complain can't
complain how you doing
i'm doing fine first things first is how
are you feeling uh you had cove at 19 i
know
um and you uh you stepped away uh
for a couple weeks how are you feeling
yeah well thanks for asking i do
appreciate that i'm feeling better now
feeling stronger
um just still got to take it easy
because
this is a very tricky and uh just uh
unpredictable virus but i'm feeling much
better and and definitely stronger now
so thanks i appreciate it of course how
can i ask how it affected you
dez oh yeah well my symptoms were or i
had um i had like this
first i like that scratchy throat
feeling the way you try to
cough like you're clearing your throat
that very annoying cough was like
like you but you know it starts to
irritate your lust i had that scratchy
throat
cough and then um i had body aches
uh especially my upper body and um
and uh you know i had sinus pressure too
uh bad sinus pressure
like in my forehead area around my eyes
and then a week
later i lost my sense of smell and taste
which i haven't
you know gotten them back fully yet so
those are my symptoms no kidding well uh
but you're you are on the mend and
obviously you're back at the
uh at your your job this week what what
is it like
at augusta have you ever been there
before is this your first time at
augusta national i
i've never been here before you know
obviously i've seen the uh
the tournament the masters and
everything and a lot of you know we
when you're in this industry you're
gonna run across a lot of people
who love golf and um so
very familiar with it and what it means
to golf and um
and then we've had like golfers you know
professional golfers
as celebrity guest pickers on the show
and so
it's this is this is really something i
guess
the only thing i could possibly equate
it to
as far as like college football is
probably like
similar to going out to pasadena and
seeing the rose bowl for the first time
because
it's just such a special venue i think
that's what the uh
being at the masters is for me so yeah i
was
actually uh in at the top of this show
um
talking about the rose bowl um one of
the first times i ever saw you play
was at the rose bowl in the 89 season i
don't know if
you were out there for the regular uh
season game against ucla that led to
what was beau schembeckler's final game
i know you played in that one
dez i remember that yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yes sir that was you that was your
first that was your first rose bowl
experience does yeah it was it was i
mean because we
we've been to several but that was like
the first one to play in and um
that was amazing i mean when you go out
that means that the pageantry the
the lawn is just like perfect you know
the
the mountains behind the stadium i mean
it just doesn't get any better than i
tell anyone i said if you're
if you're a real avid college football
fan you
love college football going to the rose
bowl
has to be on your bucket list there's no
doubt about it
it's so beautiful all right so let's get
to the the current state of affairs
in college football uh i i you know here
in the nfl we're still trying to figure
out who the best is but we've we've been
able to get most of the season in
um thank goodness with with no uh nobody
cancelled but now it's
i i mean how do i make heads or tails of
of this college football season
right now desmond oh brother listen
my man it's it's it's a challenge it
really is because
um a bunch of moving parts a bunch of
games being either postponed or
canceled um so this is work in progress
no one knows
exactly how you're going to determine
who the best teams are now
based on the eye test yes which which
you know is
you know i think you know is he's very
useful at this point i mean it's
relevant at this point
you know you would look at alabama
they've been pretty dominant you look at
um the buck guys you know those games
that they've played so far
they've been pretty dominant you know
you have a clemson i mean clemson is
still a dominant team okay they lost
notre dame
that just makes a lot of us look at
notre dame a little differently
um and obviously they beat clemson
without trevor lawrence but yet and
still i mean they scored a lot of points
on that brent venables defense i mean
people are not like giving that
the amount of um credit that that notre
dame deserves and to be honest with you
rich
notre dame should have scored more
points on clemson's defense but
they got in the red zone several times
settled for field goals
and then one time ian booked the
quarterback i mean he's like about to go
into the end zone
he just fumbles the well i don't say he
just fumbled it he was like um
brenda uh brent vinable's son who plays
linebacker
his son did like you know attempt to
tackle
ian book and on his attempt to tackling
ian's book
he got the ball out but still i mean i
think it's like inside like maybe the
10-yard line
so there are many more opportunities for
notre dame to score
touchdowns that they didn't take
advantage of so i understand that
trevor lawrence you know he's supposed
to be the number one pick in the draft
and all that good stuff and he didn't
play
but they really did a number on
clemson's defense and i don't think they
get enough credit
for the job that they did rich they sure
did i i agree with you
uh you know you got to play who's in
front of you and clemson came in
obviously without
trevor lawrence but everyone else was uh
pretty much loaded for bear
there and i'm assuming we'll see them
again in the afc
acc championship game and then we'll
just just determine
whether we want to run it back one more
time in a college football playoff
because
i i again i'm i'm looking around and i'm
trying to see who might
raise their hand and say and even in
this covet 19 season
they deserve a shot i i don't know who
else is out there dez what
what how do you handicap that right now
yeah i mean it's tough it's tough i
think i mean i would say
now up to this point of season some of
the the best teams
or some of the teams that i've seen is
playing the best football
okay we already mentioned clemson we
already mentioned alabama we already
mentioned the buckeyes and notre dame
okay
but then you kind of go off the grid
very very impressed by the byu
cougars they got this quarterback zach
wilson who's having a fantastic season
they're very
physical and um and they've been
impressive from
day one and they've been extremely
consistent so the byu is a team that i
like too and then cincinnati says nate
bearcat
when you want to look at a group of five
teams they got this quarterback desmond
ritter
he's he's playing at a high level every
week but they have a defense
man their defense is for real like like
they shut down like smu
which was a high scoring defense they
shut down memphis another high scoring
defense
and uh so like those are two outliers
when you look at
byu and you look at the cincinnati
bearcats that people are starting to
really pay attention to and to be honest
with you rich
before the season started we do a you
know we do this you know we always
predict
who's going to be in the college
football playoff and
one of my four teams um was a cincinnati
bearcats the only reason i took them out
because they were originally in because
at this point
the big ten had decided they were not
going to play
so we're not talking about you know any
team in the big ten so we eliminate the
big ten
so okay well i'm putting uh cincinnati
in there so then when
they uh did a 180 they being the big ten
and decided that they were going to have
a season
that's okay well i have to remove
cincinnati
and put in ohio state well i mean and i
spoke about
um i guess what i'm about to ask you
with mike tarico earlier this week
and i i i know it might be total fantasy
but i might
let's let's let's play it out here
because we did see major league baseball
play
in a pandemic and decide to expand their
playoffs
because uh of the truncated regular
season we already saw the nfl just this
past
week at their owner's meeting just in
case
covet 19 starts canceling games that
they
will expand the playoffs literally
making this decision that right now we
know it's one through seven
in each conference but it might be one
through eight if they have to go in this
direction we're already
seeing so many canceled games week to
week in college football
why not come out and say this year
one time only just it's a one time only
situation
let's expand the playoffs so byu and
cincinnati can make it and let's play it
out and see how it goes
i know that that presents its own issues
in terms of competition and also
the pandemic but what do you think of
that idea desmond
i mean i love giving the uh the
underdogs a legitimate shot
and playing in uh the championship game
you know play at least playing in the
playoff i
i love that opportunity you know that
that as an option
um you know but there's just so much
that goes into it
that you know we have to look at the
logistics of everything and how
you know how much um would this extend
the season
and what would this mean to the student
athletes like they always have to
take those things into consideration but
i would love to have a situation where
you have maybe cincinnati versus byu as
a playing
game where whoever wins you know they
get to play into the playoffs
actually have have another have another
two teams have four teams do a playoff
game
uh play end game um i like that idea but
like i said you get these this
student athlete how much does this
extend the season
and all that stuff desmond howard
joining me here from
augusta national uh on the rich eisen
show okay dez
uh we're going to stroll into that third
rail territory if you don't mind
because i get it uh and i didn't win a
heisman trophy for the school
uh i i get it a ton wha
what what about our alma mater what what
is happening there
now and what is the answer do you think
desmond howard yeah that's um
i know you know what i mean yeah i i
it's so tough uh uh to to talk about it
but
you know yeah we'll just chop it up
because you look at you look at
harbaugh and in his tenure so far
and like on the on the surface like
there's a lot to unpack i guess that's
the best way to say it
rich there's a lot to unpack there and
uh but on the surface
he hasn't been able to hit on the
quarterback and i think that's been his
biggest issue like he hasn't been ever
hit on the quarterback any of these
teams that we see
in college football who we're talking
about they're good enough to get to like
champ you know even the college football
playoff or
they all got great to elite quarterbacks
okay um he hasn't been able to hit on
one
now joe milton you know i've heard
fantastic things about him
i think the last game against indiana
was the first time
that i saw glimpses of what joe milton
can be and what the offense can be for
the simple fact
that they decided to go vertical
they had some vertical shots that they
hit he had
one to ronnie bale that he missed
that was an easy walk-in touchdown but
this is the first time i saw them
start to really stretch the field you
know the week before
when they played sparty they just you
know the bunch of slants and quick outs
and
drag routes but nothing really really
vertical um
but against indiana nasa okay now see
where joe milton's arm comes into play
you know and
how these these receivers they got
they're not the big ones that we
that we've had for like the last three
four five years
but they're vertical guys they're fast
guys they're speed guys so now
i can see that potential even though
they lost the other thing rich
is and i said this on the show i do
believe as as
as much as we all love don brown people
i mean i'm just i'm not talking about we
all like michigan fans
alumni i'm talking about like college
football
fans like analysts like don brown is a
highly regarded defensive coordinator
i i think that he's playing the scheme
he just doesn't have the personnel to
run though i mean these
defensive backs these cornerbacks are
getting exposed
and you know like that normally what
happened rich maybe later in the season
you know maybe against ohio state or
maybe you know when
penn state they had like a hamlet so
normally that's when it would happen but
like to see it
this early and this often um
i mean it is just you know it's kind of
alarming
and i don't know what that answer is you
know can they play zone can these guys
you know first the first time okay maybe
this guy
just had a bad game but then you look at
indiana
indiana looked at that film they said
yeah we're gonna take shots down the
field
you know and uh we're gonna see what
what they can do
so that's the second part you know that
defense
they've given up a lot of points in
big games and big games and that's been
the difference maker too and
i don't know those are like the two
things on the surface like i said
there's a lot to unpack there but when i
look at x's and those and just look at
the team
i mean ty law and charles woodson
they're not walking through that door
you know so i don't know what the answer
is defensively where they're gonna be
able to
you know run the scheme that don wants
to run and have some sort of success and
then
hutchinson is out you know we don't know
how long he's going to be
they say he has a fractured ankle or
something like that i don't know if he's
out for the season or whatnot so
that's not going to help their pass rush
either well and you want to talk about
big games wisconsin coming out of covet
hell there's no other way to describe it
um
is is walking into the big house this
weekend and i i you know i heard jim
say afterwards i heard harbaugh say
after the indiana game that there's a
lot to take out of it to be positive
about which is you know
difficult to to you know hear and
comprehend when they've just lost to an
opponent for the first time since
my sophomore year in college i think
before you even showed up in
in ann arbor in 1987 but you know right
but now here comes wisconsin that i
think wants to say
okay uh here we go what better way to
let everyone understand that even in
this crazy shortened season
it's not just ohio state and we need to
take this
side of the ledger so we can take on
ohio state in that last game of the year
and and reserve a seat for them in the
college football playoffs this is a big
game for wisconsin
coming up this weekend on saturday night
huge game huge absolutely right it's a
huge game for wisconsin
um we don't know what to expect you know
they've missed a couple weeks now
because of the uh
covet 19 and contact tracing and
we don't know they haven't played in a
while so uh the quarterback you know he
was the one who had the uh
the positive tests and well he was like
he wasn't the only one he was the first
name
that you heard but then they had correct
multiple players with the
with positive tests and that's what they
had to
quarantine for i guess i guess i i don't
even know if it's been 21 days that's
that's the
the big ten rule is you have to
quarantine at least a player
or players who test positive have to
quarantine for 21 days and i guess
i don't know if this is 21 days after
the positive test or 21 days starting
where your symptoms begin whatever you
know i'm not even sure about that
language but
uh we'll see who lines up at quarterback
and you know who who they bring out
there on the field it's going to be
really
interesting because we really don't know
oh my gosh
dez i know i know rich i kind of like
my my texts blow up from you know uh
the ohio state fans that i know and
friends about the school up north and
and the reveling is it's tough for me to
take man
it's tough to hear yeah it's tough hey
imagine
imagine being in my shoes you guys sit
there and talk about that i do
i am i come here every day and the
people call me up and
you know and i want it to work out for
for harbaugh being there so bad he's my
guy he's my quarterback
he's my freshman year quarterback he's
the guy who and the kids who come in are
very talented it's not
like the cupboard's totally bare you
know what i mean it's
that's right a lot to unpack as you put
it so
uh before i let you go um what is
saturday's show going to look like
um walk me through what what uh college
game day uh at uh
at augusta nationals going to look like
it's going to be a
uh a good um mix
of what we always do but some uh
some mixture of of of the masses of golf
you know and
you know we'll probably have some
players you know depending on their tea
time
um do interviews because the thing about
it is
these guys a lot of them they have
some sort of affiliation with the
college football team
and they love college football so
they'll you know
this is an opportunity for them to show
another side of their personality
um you know that's not just you know
golfing it gives them
opportunities just kind of like relax
because imagine you playing you know
masters on the saturday and you know the
tension and everything but
you know now you get a chance to like
talk college football and let your
personality come out and relax so
there'll be a good
mixture of um blending in you know
some of the golfers who uh who are
teeing off or who are
uh playing during the hours that we're
on air so it should be fun it should be
nice it should be
great for our audience to see those
personalities and for obviously
the master's audience to see us so does
does
corso have like a tiger woods um
head to put on or something like that
are we going to see
something like that what what do you got
for me on the corso front
for saturday i don't know what that that
dude is doing down in orlando there's no
telling what he's cooking up that's a
good question
i'm anxious to see what he's cooking up
down there too so
let's see uh we'll see saturday because
i don't know what he got planned he's
probably tiger's neighbor
he's probably got you know he probably
goes a cup of sugar and asks for
you know ken griffey for a cup of sugar
knowing him you know you're probably
right
hey guys it's great to hear you and
great to hear your laugh and i'm so glad
that uh
coveted 19 um that you're you're you're
getting through
uh you're getting through it best you
can and as well as you are back on i
can't wait to see you back on tv
no thank you i really appreciate that
thanks for having me on your show but
man keep up the great work
boys please right back at you that's
desmond howard one of my all-time
favorites
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here